تستعرض كوريا الشماليه قوتها جوا وبحرا
تاره بصاروخ باليسي عابر للقارات ومره
اخرى بغواصه تحدث انفجار نوويا تحت المياه
يتسبب فيما وصفته بتسونامي اشعاعيا واسع
النطاق السلاح السري هكذا اسمت بيون جانج
تلك الغواصه واختبرتها لثلاثه ايام واجرت
كوريا الشماليه التدريبات قباله مقاطعه هم
جونغ الجنوبيه وفجرت راسا حربيا تجريبيا
بعد ان طافت لمده 59 ساعه واثنتي عشره
دقيقه على عمق 80 الى 150 مترا مشيره الى
ان هذه الغواصه يمكن نشرها على اي ساحل او
ميناء وسحبها بواسطه سفينه سطحيه
وبينما تحاول كوريا الشماليه ان تثبت
نفسها كقوه نوويه تلقي بيون جانج باللائمه
على تجربه درع الحريه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه والتي تقوض الامن
الاقليميه على حد قولها فبعد انزعاج كوريا
الشماليه من التعاون الدفاعي المشترك اقر
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
ان هذه المناورات ليست الا بمثابه تحذير
للولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه من اجل
ادراك القدره غير المحدوده لجمهوريه كوريا
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه اما كوريا الجنوبيه
وردا على كل تلك التجارب جددت على لسان
رئيسها العهد بالحرص على ان تدفع كوريا
الشماليه الثمن ولو بعد حين